Next question, I was able to get a Pruduo skin. So remember, we talked about the Pruduo
skin. That is like, if an MRI got married to a CT skin, got married to a PET skin and
they had a baby. So the Pruduo skin, the other huge benefit of the Pruduo skin, it does
not use any contrast dyes. You're not using any injectable glucose, you're not using any
swallowed glucose, nothing like that. So it is like a perfect scan. The only problem is there's
only, I think, five of them in the nation right now. What is in the outskirts of Western
Southern Pacific, Twin Cities, Minneapolis, St. Paul? What is it? Atlanta, you could look it up
through Newspark and you could look up Google it. During the last, receive the results yesterday,
during the last year and a half, I've been dealing with unhealed, wound after using black
salve. So it seems in the meantime that the breast tumor has grown to 8.5 centimeters and they found
lesion scattered in my lungs and skeleton. Not what I wanted to hear, but I'm investigating insulin
potentiation therapy. So insulin-potentiated chemotherapy is a way to do low dose chemotherapy, but you're
giving a shot at insulin to this person a period of time before dosing the chemotherapy and you're
able to give a much lower dose of chemotherapy. We've had numerous patients throughout the years do
this with great success. So there's a has of negatives to it as well. You don't get as nearly as much
side effects as doing high dose regular chemotherapy, but you have to do a lot more sessions. You have
to move to the area where you're doing it because it's really like course of three months.
So that could be an issue for some people. You can still lose your hair, you can still,
because you're getting more doses, you're getting greater number of sessions.
So, but it's much less harsh on the body. We give it insulin-potentiated chemotherapy. That's
about 10% of the dose. Would you recommend the same protocol for prepping for chemo? No, I wouldn't.
I would not go off my, that's just me personally. Of course, you want to talk to the clinic
any but any clinic that's doing the insulin-potentiated chemotherapy is very alternative.
My did so they're not going to just give you this. Oh, you got to go off all your supplements.
But if they say, hey, we really would like you to go off of your antioxidants,
then I would follow their recommendations and we could help you with that. But if they say, no,
you can stay on your stuff, I would stay on my stuff. Two questions I asked before couldn't find
where your answer had done. Do you have a read on a good comparison of how much sugar is in a pet skin?
Like is it several kinds of pop? I can't even find that number of glucose when I Google it.
No, that's first time I ever heard that question. So, I don't, if somebody else does, if you could
chime in, that would be great. I don't know what I can't remember at any books that I read that they
gave a comparison. And then how quickly do cancers mutate and do rife updates keep up?
With breast cancer, you really don't have to update your program unless you have
known metastasis, which if you didn't have known metastasis before, I can't remember and
it'll look at your file. And now you have metastasis, then we'll want to update your frequencies. So,
contact us to update your frequencies. If you, if you never knew, you had metastasis before.
And with that by that, I mean, these scattered lesions and the lungs and skulls. And even though
they haven't been diagnosed as a metastasis, if the Purdue will pick that up as a possibility,
we will want to change your program and add some programming for that as well.